因为AI
咨询公司的好日子到头了
但本着打不过就加入的原则
他们直接把钱
送给了对手
这就是OpenAI的新业务
Deployment Company
部署公司
这家公司
不卖模型
但是却做AI咨询
本质上
就是一家AI版的麦肯锡
融资40亿
估值100亿
咱们先来说说
传统咨询怎么了
过去几十年
麦肯锡、贝恩这些咨询公司
靠的是信息差
客户不懂的
他们来研究
现在 企业完全可以用
AI来做研究
于是 企业的需求变成了
我们怎么样部署AI解决方案
还有谁比AI公司自己
更适合做这件事呢
于是 部署公司公布当天
埃森哲、Cognizant
Infosys股价同步下跌
更讽刺的是
部署公司投资名单里有
贝恩、麦肯锡、Capgemini
这三家知名咨询公司
同样是部署公司的
直接竞争对手
换句话说
咨询公司在掏钱
帮OpenAI做自己的竞品
这就是咨询的变革
那OpenAI成立这家新公司
对它来说又有什么好处呢
答案是
在和Anthropic争夺
上市窗口期的关键时刻
企业用户是最值钱的战场
OpenAI的首席营收官就透露
随着GPT-5.5的放出
企业业务占OpenAI收入40%
预计年底会和消费业务持平
但光卖API已经不够了
随着模型越来越强
AI能帮企业做的事情
越来越多
也越来越难
但大部分企业
并不知道怎么把AI应用到
真实的工作场景里
部署公司 提出了一个概念
“前线部署工程师”（FDE）
这些人会直接进入企业内部
和团队从零开始
重新设计工作流
前置驻场工程师深入业务团队
贴近终端用户
吃透实际业务流程
协助将后台办公应用中的
各项功能能力迁移出来
对接接入智能模型
最终为每一个业务流程环节
赋能智能化能力
和咨询公司比
OpenAI自己做这件事
还有一个优势
那就是这些前线工程师
很熟悉下一代模型的能力方向
这也就意味着
企业今天建的系统
是为未来而设计的
为了加速落地
OpenAI还收购了Tomoro
一家AI咨询工程公司
带来了150名
有实战经验的工程师
他们服务过像Tesco
维珍航空这样的企业用户
而几乎同一时间啊
Anthropic也做了同一件事
Anthropic成立企业AI服务公司
背后有黑石、Hellman
高盛的投资
OpenAI这家部署公司
背后也是二十家私募的钱
我们知道
私募巨头旗下
有大量传统软件公司
也是受AI冲击
最大的一类公司
所以这些投资人
自然也会成为
OpenAI部署公司的第一块试金石
这个模式能不能跑通
当然还有很多未知数
AI到底对咨询行业
有多大的冲击
前端工程师
可以代替战略顾问吗
对于这个问题
如果大家感兴趣的话
欢迎在评论区留言
我们也会做更深入的探讨
关注硅谷101
不要错过最前沿的
科技和商业动态